gay pete continued he's making the
rounds you know instead of doing work
he's uh he's making the rounds and he
was on charlemagne he's charlemagne the
god is that what they call them the god
that's a
dave reuben
the god
he's on charlemagne the god he's got a
radio show i guess and uh charlemagne
tells pete pete black people don't like
you
you do realize pete um
a lot of black people feel like
democrats have kept no promises
since they've been in since they've been
in office really yes
robert island said that a million times
let me show you i mean pressing you okay
look i get it
one more time
you do realize pete um
a lot of black people feel like
democrats have kept no promises
since they've been in since they've been
in office really yes reverend island
said that a million times let me show
you i mean pressing you okay
look i get it really yes look i get it
did it did it i get it yeah yes you
don't
do you don't keep your promises
democrats actually instill all of the
policies that have kept black people
more impoverished let's say than white
people or whatever phrase you want to
use on that the welfare state which
destroyed the black family and then
keeps people in in generational poverty
rita thomas sober really really but i
say i like black people we're lgbt we're
black we're everything we got a little
bit of everything we love everybody
because we're always talking about
everybody
god these people
anyway they are they're just everything
lying so what do we got here what do we
got we got there the lying about covid
the lying about the gender stuff and
then of course and this will
bring us home here
the lying about race which is exactly
what that was they lie about race
remember donald trump that orange man
spoke at the state of the union and
talked about all-time low black
unemployment and the congressional black
caucus sat there like this
african-american unemployment stands at
the lowest rate ever recorded
oh you think we're supposed to applaud
low black unemployment you're orange man
we ain't gonna do it okay
liars and evil freaks that's what they
are